there we go it's nine o'clock
thanks everyone for coming
i have a couple questions to sort of
gauge the room how many of you this is
your first conference since covid
are any of you nervous about being here
like i am
just me
[Laughter]
i haven't given a talk in like three
years so i'm a little
rattled but everything should be fine my
name is sean wildermuth i'm a
pluralsight author speaker all that
other stuff i have a title page here but
i'm not going to
belabor it
um i want to talk about tailwind and how
many of you
have used tailwind already
one okay that's the right audience
you're gonna have to check to make sure
everything i say is is right so that's
your job right okay
um and how many of you enjoy doing css
that's also the right
audience for this
so
the big thing i want to sort of start
with is this idea of what is tail and
css because when i first ran into tail
in css my initial reaction was this is
another bootstrap this is another
thing that will make my website look
like every other website out on the web
right the what i used to call the boot
stratification of the web right everyone
had the same title bar and drop-downs
and all that
and as i dug into it it is a bit
different one it's a pure css framework
there's no javascript that's running in
the background it doesn't have
components in that same way it's really
for styling your classes in the way you
want to with some
customization but also
a consistency that you don't really get
by writing your own css
that typically produces a really tiny
version of the css in production which
is one of the things i really liked
about it and there is a bill a dev um
a development time build process as part
of it
because one of the things it's doing and
we'll see in a minute
is it's building the css as you're doing
development and making that css bigger
as you you utilize more of these utility
classes
so ima does anyone want to see a bunch
more slides
this is the only other slide that
matters um so we're going to get into
code let me start with the project and
we're going to spend a lot of time
just making this project i have a little
um website if i could get rid of the
there we go little website that just
allows me to look at some api i made up
and uh
so far you know it looks okay it's not
great um
and the way i've developed it
isn't with tailwind
see that text large enough or should i
make it larger for people in the back
good
i'll take silence
and what i've done to create that is i
actually to have
a all hand coded
css like i've done for the last
15 or 20 years right i've just gone in
and
written all this by hand
um and i uh
i could have done this in fact i think
i can't remember if i'm using scss in
here or not no i could have done this
with sas or less or one of the other
libraries
and so we're going to sort of start from
scratch and just ignore that
css entirely we're going to go to the
index.html and i'm going to
do the thing no one likes to see
get rid of the css right
and our lovely site turns into
that let me see if i'm connected to the
internet
i forgot about the
sorry about that you know i was gonna
forget connecting one of these things
come on
you go clockwise to make the connection
speed up i don't know if you're aware of
that just don't go counterclockwise
really
okay
um so this is the same website i had a
moment ago but there's no css associated
with it right this is just pure html
there's really a mess that i need to
kind of figure out how to work with and
so i'm going to start by just adding css
tailwind
from a cdn
now if you want to sort of play whoops
if you want to sort of play with
why does it keep on opening up that
there is a tailwind
cdn
it's almost like i'm jet lagged
that you can sort of get started but
this is not what you want to use in your
project it's missing a number of
features that you'll might utilize and
it's also using javascript to sort of
figure out what scripts to use so it's a
pretty inefficient one but it's to
enable us to get started before we get
into actually how tailwind works
and so
with tailwind installed it's changed a
tiny bit maybe hard to see
but none of the
elements
have any styles it's doing a complete
reset to the style so the drop down box
there doesn't have any borders or
margins or anything h1s aren't any
bigger than any any other text it's
doing a complete reset
and so let's just start using it so i
have a
nope i have a site name here
and i have been using css classes for
the id but the idea behind
tailwind is really to say
uh i want to be able to style this from
scratch and i'm going to just use
classes so first of all i can say
text 2xl so there's sizes of text from
extra small up to 5x so you can kind of
decide how large the text need to be
this is where a second screen will come
into
help
2xl
why don't you like that
bold
and
space
and there are a number of these utility
classes you can see that each one is
really defining some
property of the thing we want to see
so we can now see the beckle test is now
larger and fonts i mean in bold and
later on we'll see that it's not going
to wrap as we start to re-develop our
product our our website
and so the way we've i've structured
this specific site is i have a header
a main section and then a footer and
we're going to
start to use those at first to sort of
structure
the site
and so let's start up here
with a class that says
background
amber
and each of the colors that are built in
and you can customize these colors
have a range of 50 to 900 for how
um how dark they are 900 is a really
dark version of that color 50 is barely
there and so if i do something like 200
and i may have disabled the
add-in that should be oh i know why it's
not working we'll get tailwind
intellisense in a minute when we're
using it not through the cdn
but we can see now we've made it a
beautiful
color of baby throw up right
and what we also want to do is go down
here to the container which used to
be our container
and i'm going to say mx.auto and that
means make the margin m
x for
left and right at the same time so you
could do left top bottom or just for all
of them i'm going to say auto which is
going to center
this container on the page
and i'm going to set it to a different
color
and
this is showing it but it doesn't really
have a width to it yet so we're going to
actually add one more class that
depending on what you're doing is i can
make this a container class which is
going to make it the size
a responsive size based on what the what
the device with
so a lot of what we're looking at is
just a couple of classes here or there
and let's do the last piece before we
start to dig into how it works is i'm
going to
add a wrapper around the header
not delete the entire one
you add a wrapper around the entire
object there and i'm going to add a new
class here
and i'm going to say
um
flex
right and so depending on how you want
to do
the um
layout what's interesting here is
they've used the names that make sense
to the actual names but try to simplify
some of the
complexities of it
so now we can see they're side by side
because flex is automatically columns by
default
or one row whichever way you want to
think about it and so we're starting to
get the beginning of this idea
so
let's talk about um well let me make one
more change and that is to make our
header
a different color as well
let's do what 800
and i'm going to add a padding p1 all
around
inside that container
and text
white though i could have choose the
color that another color like gray 50 if
i wanted it not quite all white
and i was told you have to name the
classes correctly for it to work
i was told
that's weird
i'm going to pretend that works
oh thank you
have you ever done pair programming with
35 people in the room it's lovely by the
way you didn't catch that that's your
job to remember
okay good
so now we have our beautiful website
it's done right we've put
three
things
the problem is that we're still loading
in this javascript and it's trying to do
runtime compilations not great and so
we'd like to move that to development
time
so i'm going to open up a console here
and just add it i happen to be using
npm already so it's gonna utilize that
but you don't have to actually have npm
on the machine amina in your project to
make it work
uh the first thing we're gonna do i
always get this wrong so i have a cheat
sheet
isn't it
npx
dell in css init and this will go ahead
and create your basic
um
files that you need
and basically what it's done is it's
created this
tailwind config file
and this is something that's going to be
used by tailwind to figure out
how you want to build the project
and so the first thing we're going to do
is we're going to tell it hey
the content i want you to look at
because part of what tailwind is going
to do is scan your files html template
files javascript files for class names
that tell one knows about
to inject them into the css that it's
going to use and that's how it makes it
so small
and so i'm just going to say
source
html
and javascript
i'm also going to do the same for public
in case i end up putting some things
there as well
now these contents are important because
if you just put star.star and include
everything it's going to try to find
everything in your node modules folder
and if you have many plug-ins it's going
to make it take forever
to work so
first thing is really defining where
your content is and of course changing
this at every at every
point and so let's whoops
down here i'll go ahead and create a
new
uh css file and i'm just calling it
source so that i know that it's the
beginning one
and in order for it to know how to build
your css it has to have a source file
that just includes three pieces tailwind
base
tail end
components
and tail end
utilities so basically it's allowing you
to specify what order these parts of cs
are injected because order matters in
here and we'll actually we'll see an
example later we can actually do
layers to say here's some css that you
don't cover that i want to be in this
part of the css and that's all done in
this in this file pretty simply
so the last thing we need to do is
actually tell it to uh run it
and you can install this in your project
or you can just use another npx just
tailwind css
import is source um
style
and output is going to be
public
styles.css
or whatever we you want to call it
so it took about 106 milliseconds to do
this from our original site what do we
get we get the styles here
that for some reason has nothing in it
let's see if i
messed up the config
yep
that makes all the difference
come on sean
you knew how to do this
an hour
ago oh it took an extra three
milliseconds
really
what don't you like
no oh yeah i do
it's the little things
had to do something we ate up another
40.
and so here we have
our css file wow that's a lot really a
lot of this is about reset you can turn
off reset if you want to and this will
become even smaller but you can see the
ones we've used flex
white space wrap
just the two color
ambers we're using all of those are
being applied here
and if we just went ahead and did and we
could add this certainly to the npm
scripts whoops
we can also do this same thing and just
say dash w and it'll just watch in the
background and make changes to the css
we need make sense
so let's change our
script here
into
css style.css
you can see that it did an incremental
build of
a whopping 18 milliseconds every time it
sees one of these files that it's
watching any of these files change
including
i think thankfully because so many so
many projects don't seem to do this when
you change the config it will also
rebuild which
i don't know how many times i was doing
a watch i changed the config and i was
like why isn't it working
did i put it in no styles
there we go
oops
no i don't want to learn about edge
so we've got sort of our starting point
here um for running it and now we can
sort of continue to go through the
styling of how this works and see some
of the utility classes because really
once you've got the build working it's
just about utilizing these utility
classes so let's start there
i'm going to come down here to my
main section whoops
the results which really just have a
collection of these film objects
and i'm going to start by just saying
class
grid
calls and you can see now we're getting
the tailwind intellisense because it's
we're actually using tailwind inner
project with a config file um there
isn't a special add-in for this the
basic code
in visual studio css
intellisense work i'm not sure in other
editors but certainly in those two it
works
so i'm going to say 3 and i'm going to
say gap
equals 2. gap is just the space in
between the columns
right we're getting there pretty close
to what we had originally of course it's
all kind of ugly and we'll sort of
continue from there
but let me introduce you to one of the
things that i really like about it is
to actually say grid one but lg
grid calls two
there's five break points in um
tailwind the
the smallest one doesn't have a modifier
so when i say
grid columns 1 it's going to apply to
every
responsive
page and then there's small medium large
extra large and 2x for different size of
screens by using this modifier on the
class lg colon
it's saying at that break point
change this property this isn't unique
to grids this isn't across the entire
project these modifiers are a big part
of what i like here
is it allows me to keep the same
nomenclature without having classes that
are specific to each of those items
just having those break points in there
and so unsurprisingly
unsurprisingly it's not working at all
grid calls two just make sure i didn't
mess something else up maybe i didn't
save it
upgrade columns two
as we go down it'll be obvious columns
one yeah everything you would expect
from
um responsive layout so all of that is
really built in with these modifiers
we're going to see some um other
modifiers here we're going to see
um let's actually do a couple more
things let's say
medium for two
and large is grid calls
four
and we'll see the same behavior i
probably don't need to show you every
one but that's when you see that that's
really the the idea about what we're
doing here is four and then we get into
the two and then we get to the one
and you get to do the same thing with
hidden and changing font size and all of
that is going to continue to work so
that you can think about the breakpoints
as simply modifiers
that you can stack on so when you need
more it does mean that you're getting
into this
situation where your classes end up
being really large and this is the chief
complaint around tailwind for some
people they feel like it is um
making their html too busy
the perf ramifications i've been told
are really small i haven't really been
able to do tests myself to see if
15 classes versus one meta class is that
much faster the speed of the
css being smaller i think is going to
mitigate
any perf differences that are there but
we can um sort of capture these and
let's let's talk about that next uh
so let's change these films real quick
so i'm just going to give it a border
a rounded
lg and that's a large size round that's
not about the break point because it
would be
lg colon if it was about the breakpoint
say a gray of
say 300 in fact i'm going to make it
semi-transparent by putting slash 50 for
the class name so being able to set
transparency without having to think of
it in a different way
there are only certain uh tran um uh
uh trans uh what am i looking for
transparent levels i think there's 10 25
50 75 66 and 100 or something like that
but there's you're not gonna be able to
put 32 and have it magically work as far
as i know
frankly i
never tried
why do i keep on hitting that one
did i forget to save it again
oh
because it's only on this first film
so in this case i only have it on the
first film and it's actually
disappearing because this film is
actually the placeholder
right this is just the placeholder
that's getting replaced at runtime when
it calls the api so instead of here
uh by the way the this example isn't
using any framework it's all
vanilla that's not about that i think
you should do it this way but i didn't
want anything else being sort of in the
way of the the topic we're talking about
so come down to results.js where i've
done a very clumsy
template here
for each of those films these are being
filled out by every
result i'll go ahead and add this here
let's make sure i saved it oh i haven't
seen
say again
oh thank you so much
if i was any good
just don't tell ndc that i'm this
awkward
really
let's just make sure it's
actually adding these
why did i take my glasses off so i could
see you guys
yeah it's still not putting them in
there what didn't i do
see if it's just a caching of my js
nope
film
that is very strange
oh oh i know why
sorry about this
i'm using roll up
though i need to do uh npm
run
down
that way the um
css the javascript gets recompiled from
i forgot about that okay i'm using one
tool in the um
so we can see that and the border is
really light so let's just go ahead in
here and say
border
let's say black just to be quick
so we can see how these are are simply
bordered and i haven't done a whole lot
to like worry about exactly what they
look like
and the last thing we'll do when we dig
into some other things is let's go
up to the container in index.js by the
way you may have not been amazed by this
but i was the first time he was able to
find these class names inside my
javascript files and this would work
angular view react they all will look in
those source files view files are
supported and jsx and tsx and all of
that
but back here let's go ahead and
go to my
object here and i'm going to
add a built-in style though i could
usually i could always change this to a
class if i want but because i want to
specify
a
background image
come on
it's gonna be
image bg seats
and i'm gonna add a class in here called
cover
i'm sorry back bg cover to tell it how i
want it to lay out that background
and so now we can see that we're getting
that background image here and we're
able to see through because of the
transparency like we're getting a lot of
what we want really out of the gate for
the kind of the style we want
let's make one more change just to make
myself happy which is text white
so it's a little more readable make
sense
so let's talk about the header for a
minute
one of the things that you may have
noticed
here in this header is that we have a
drop down here that has no styling
whatsoever it's it's inheriting the
white text i put in the con in the
header here and it's trying to do the
right things with by picking the year
you're you're
looking at and these are actually
buttons again with no styling
now if you don't want to start from
scratch which is fine
you can go into the config and add a new
piece that um called core plugins
i used to know how to type
don't get old people
to do your talks
um so the way they've engineered
tailwind is this idea of plugins and
core plugins so you can extend it or the
core plug-ins are each of the pieces and
so you can actually say
pre-flight
which is the resetting the css reset i
can just say false
and in that case if i go to the right
window
we'll see that we now get those
default but ugly
forms and so you can see that the mouse
over
all the
a's all the anchors are getting that
horrible default look and so we're gonna
have to do more so i actually like
to leave it in but i'll
this comes
this out in case you ever
download this demo
so we can really make these work and
let's start with the button
i keep on going to that page
so we have a class of button here
and i'm just going to style it by saying
padding 1 so there's some room between
it and the border i'm going to go ahead
and say border and border
uh
let's say yellow
let me get a bit
in the background
uh amber
whoops
and text white although it's actually
gonna inherit that
there we go
and
that should all be there did i save it
now that's annoying
oh that's the pager anyway
that's the pager that doesn't show up on
the first page so no wonder we can't see
it
sorry about that
so i'm going to go to this first
menu
we can see here we have this a tad ugly
but it is a button that works now
but we want to really feel like a button
and so let's make a couple more little
changes
let's go rounded and
um
let's do
hover
bg color
i'm sorry bg amber
let's make it maybe
700 to make it get
and so now through css
i'm getting that behavior i want without
having to really think about writing
these on you're not going to be able to
you still need to attach an event here
but the kind of behavior that you want
css to do is built in you're going to
see a number of these modifiers and
hover is one that i use
quite a lot
but we have an essential problem
in
that i just made it too small um
we have a central problem that
this is going to be really annoying to
copy
to every
button right this is the case where just
using the classes might not be good
enough so i'm going to take that out and
i'm going to go back to our
source
and i'm going to say in the layer
components
i want to write some um css that you're
going to use and i'm going to say oh i
have a
class called button which we already
have on all those items it doesn't need
to be a class it could be a
it could be inputs or any css selector
and i'm going to say at apply
that
what this is going to do is allow you
when you do need reuse to take those
same classes that you prototyped in the
browser throw them into an apply and now
you have a class that's going to work
and you can see them now
they're all buttons all four well you
can't see the fourth one but all five
buttons but
the one isn't being shown are now
applying that button now the one here
gets black instead of white because
we're inheriting it from that container
the color so we could of course of
course put white in there
let's make two more
changes here
go ahead and tell it to
put a margin of one just give us a
little space around it and with
full
right
went out closer to what we wanted to do
and then we
could of course come in here because we
don't have a selected
button dot selected which is how i'm
specifying which of the buttons have
been pressed i could just say add apply
whoops
either i'm too tall or this podium's too
short
uh hover
no unselected say um
i know i was going to forget the name of
this class i always do
it's not hover it is
ring
ring which is a special kind of thing
and it says to envelop an object with
another level of color around the border
and i'm gonna say
ring two just to make it a bit thicker
so it's obvious
and ring
yellow
i'm gonna choose a really bright yellow
so you can see it
oh
i don't need ring and ring two ring two
is the thicker version of the ring and
so you notice here in the intellisense
it's actually giving us
you'll see this in the editor as well
it's giving us an error here because the
error is that the same
class property is affecting the same
property itself which is super useful
for going uh oh
what did i just do
so as we change these we can now see the
selected changes with a little rainwork
right
and i'm doing this in code by adding the
or removing the select selected class
but it doesn't know about
the actual functionality it's just
saying oh when it looks like when it's
in this state go ahead and do this
certain thing
that makes sense
let's do the same thing with the drop
down
in the case of the drop down since i'm
only going to have one probably through
my whole app i might just do it in line
which is what i'll do here you could
certainly make a class and
this is one of the places where
the person who created tailwind and i
differ
thinks that you should almost never use
apply and i think you should use it
where it makes sense but what you
shouldn't do and i think in both of our
opinions is try to take all those
classes and create special classes for
them it sort of breaks
the idea of uh simplicity in what you're
doing and being very self-describing so
notice in the film i used all the tags
because there was code that was
repeating that
over and over i could have just made it
a film class and used apply but i don't
know that i would have gained much
because
i'm seeing what the style is when i'm
editing that film block versus having to
go look in the css to see what i need to
change but it's a personal opinion how
much or little you use
i think his problem is um most of the
bugs he's spot in the last three months
have been about apply so he might be a
little
pained by apply wish he never put it in
or something but
it's too late it's out there right
so let's go to the select here
i'm going to do the same sort of thing
i'm going to say rounded
border
um
i'll just border
and uh
border color whoops
uh black
and
text um
the word i'm looking for
text white thank you
so we see this
sort of working oh it did make it white
it didn't make the background dark i
forgot to do one
let's actually simplify this with
text
come on
and bg
uh i'll do use amber again
of let's say 800. so it's nice and dark
so now we can see in it you notice it's
including based on the the color what
the drop-down element is and so let's
make this a little bit more pretty and
large like the other ones by just saying
say padding2
with full
we could obviously change the background
color if we wanted to and even change
the text size so text size is an
interesting one because
um what they have are these you can see
text base exercise small up to i believe
it's 5x
yeah so there's a wide range in these
sort of levels they don't want to
prescriptively define what those are but
what uh will happen in a lot of places
i'll go ahead and just use
uh text large here
just so it looks a little bit like and i
could even make it bold but what will
often happen in my projects is i will
have a
inside the layer components
h1
apply
text
3xl or something like that and then do
the same for all the h's to sort of
re-hydrate those at the levels we're
talking about
and notice at no point in any of this
are these classes specifying pixel size
or rams or anything the the resulting
css are in rem so that it's gonna behave
appropriately and resize screens and all
of those sorts of things
but they're trying to build up uh the
comfort to um
have these sort of known
sizings so if we look at the
uh
i don't have the source open yet
we'll look at text
large you see there they have these
specific sizes associated with them size
and line height that it's using and
those
uh those the bases for all those are
configurable so if you don't like the
large size being that size you can make
it up or down
uh just in the config file there's ways
to override that or even have themes for
different cases like maybe you have a
theme for one customer even though
you're using a main site and that theme
would have all these sort of overrides
that are applicable just to them
so in many ways unlike
a lot of the layout libraries out there
it's really meant for
developers to
have
build time instances of tailwind to give
us the most flexibility without having
to necessarily write a lot of the css
now this doesn't preclude you writing
css
i used apply there but i could have
certainly put in my own
classes and there's no conflict as long
as they're not using the same name and
you'll just run into the um
the order problem so one of the things
that happens is some of the names in
here actually exist in some of the other
frameworks like
like um bootstrap
and
uh
as soon as i added tailwind to it
instead of removing bootstrap i just
added it in order to get some of the
classes of course i was conflicting so
every p1 which is a different size than
the p1 in um
tailwind
things are going crazy because they're
fighting that who last in wins and more
specific css rules that you have to
think about
so let's uh
let's do this in a more common way whoa
steaming up my glasses
so over here in the source
let's do a tailwind
base here
and i'm going to create a new one that's
called control
base
because a lot of what i'm doing here
should probably be the same
for a lot of the controls
why doesn't it like that
oh
sorry bass isn't uh
where we need to do this needs to be in
components because
a lot of those doesn't like it did i
forget to
i mean round it isn't
it's
right
there must have done something different
here
come on sean
there we go
um i'm trying to use classes that aren't
defined
at the end of base they're actually
defined in the beginning of components
so that's why i was giving me that error
because it's sort of building these as
we need them
and so
we could then simply just replace all of
this
with unsurprisingly
control base right
so you can use this sort of hierarchy in
the same way and when you
apply this
actually let me see it applied to make
sure i'm not lying to you
because it's happened before that i made
the assumption
um
button
come
you can see the things that i applied
the button aren't
um referring to the base css they're
actually apply as taking
a
mix of all the css that are defined in
the other classes and putting in here
including your own
base css classes as well
so you have that sort of um
componentization of your ui without
having to have the
detriment of having to look up or
whatever it's
uh putting out the most specific css it
possibly can
and so we could apply that same thing
here though i'm not going to
worry about a little but let's go into
the source again
because one of the things i don't like
is there's not quite enough space
between either of these so i'm going to
tell my buttons
i could say margin
one which obviously puts a little margin
on the outside but i i don't want that i
could say margin
y
which gives it a top and a bottom of a
little larger
but i can also do mx
i'm sorry
m left
and right
let's see how much i've broken this
bottom and top right you have control
over which sort of levels you need to do
that with and let's
undo this until i've unbroken it
there we go
so i'm just going to say
my
one just to make sure there's a little
bit more space in here
and for some reason i've made a little
too wide for my full width and this is
the full width is changing you still
need to understand css a little
because the full width is making the
content of the button 100 wide but i
have a
a a padding on the left and right hand
side which is adding to that button size
or it might be a margin see what i did
here
yeah
so let's actually just put
the padding y here
and it's still a little large i'd have
to figure out why that is
my other demo it isn't there and i'm
sure it's something weird i'm doing
um but we can you can see how building
the css one of the things i like here is
i can really just spend my time
editing and checking editing checking
but the thing that makes this harder
is that if you're used to developing
your css in the browser with the with
the editor window and just adding your
properties and seeing how they go
it doesn't know about those changes in
the browser and so if that's your
pattern and you're comfortable with it
tailwind might not be the right option
for you
because the reality uh is that this is
just another tool
i like it for a lot of the projects i do
but that doesn't mean it's the one true
css god right if you're using sas and
you're getting everything you need
maybe this isn't the time to change this
is one of those
cases where for the right project and
developer set this is a great tool i
really like it but please don't come
away from this talk is like everyone
should be moving to
this or everyone should be using oh he
said bootstrap i'm gonna have to take
bootstrap out of all my projects the
world doesn't work like that and uh
at the end i think pragmatism is more
important about these issues
i have a client who was like i saw your
tailwind video do i need to put it in
i'm like no please just no you
you've got an aspx i'm sorry an asp site
full of other problems putting in
tailwind is not going to solve any of
those
right
it's the last thing you should be
looking at
um
ends up feeling you know better
make sure i haven't uncovered any of
these other i did that
oh and i'm going to do just a couple
more things just to make this
a mostly workable site so down here in
the footer
you notice this footer
is kind of ugly right
just left justified and so i'll just do
what i normally would do is just add
just make all the windows pop up at once
and then add
text center
padding let's say two
i'm not going to use margin i'm going to
make it another color
amber
um
let's say 700 and text
white
and so now our
it's a little nicer right it's kind of
what you expect you could have a lot
more data in there but for now that's
that's perfectly good enough
uh
oh
so here's an example of my
100 width on the
buttons doesn't really work right and so
this may be oh you know what i just need
to
change the
source to not have
pull here and then to apply them only to
the ones
in my object and i could do
header
dot button or i could um
add it as well i'm going to see if that
works i've never
tried this instead of doing it so i
might have just broken it all yep
as long as i broke it that's all that
matters
probably not called header
i just called header okay let's just fix
it that way
right they have the same sort of
behavior
and in some cases let's go to
all the passing films in
1977.
we'll get this monstrosity right i
really hate this i don't want it to
force
um the i don't want to stick the footer
to the bottom but i do want to avoid the
case where there's only a couple of
names here
and so i'm just going to come back to
index and i'm going to make
the header that you could do it to both
of these i'm just going to say
min
height
screen
right
and then no matter what the result is
i think 1970 just had one result the
header is going to be there you might
want to do the same thing to make this
larger as well but the header is forcing
that vector test because i've told the
header to be the width of the screen
not
the width of screen minus the size of
the header
and none of this is about
um
absolute positioning but all of the
things you think about in positioning
and layout flex
grid
uh block
inline et cetera they're all have their
own classes for you to do that sort of
thing
and the last thing i'll mention we don't
it's not really necessary here but i
love this
let's say i'm having a problem with
override and i know i'm not supposed to
ever use
important
but if i need to because i've screwed
something up
you put a exclamation point in front of
it and it becomes important
there's a few of those that are just
sort of modifiers in the same way
because this took me a little while to
figure out if i did want
let's say a padding of two
or let's say margin of two
but i don't want a margin of two i want
a margin of minus 2
that's the class right
margin dash minus 2 is a negative margin
makes sense
so we've got about 10 minutes for
questions
anything i didn't cover you wanted me to
cover have any questions about how it
works or why it works
i'm just going to start picking on
people if no one has any questions
you don't you don't believe me do you
to the person who have has used tailwind
before did you see anything that you
haven't learned before
oh good
oh great
awesome
that's the right answer in case you
don't know what color to pick out front
if you're confused by the whole system
it defaults to green so
whatever you need to do
well if you're out of caffeine like i'm
out of caffeine we could end a little
early if no one has questions or if
you're too shy i'll stay up here for
five minutes and answer any specific
questions about this or anything you
want to talk about
anything else
uh you can define the base of that color
and then it'll do the automatic uh
application um of those colors as well
so defining your own color names or
overwriting this existing name just
normally you're saying something like
amber base or
our corporate pink
base
and then have it apply the customization
is pretty deep you can customize how it
builds at a default level or create
these things called themes which are
basically
named
uh you would set the theme to on the top
of a page that you could change and then
that theme would wholly take over for
anything you that wasn't defined
that was defined in that theme so it
gives you a lot of control
if you uh dark and light theme are the
probably the most common use of that but
they're just named themes so it doesn't
matter
others by the way dark and light theme
is turned off by default there's a
boolean i think it's called use dark
that you put on and then all of those
values change based on the theme of the
system you're on
it's doing the same detection of
windows mac and
mobile for what color the theme is of
the application a lot of times most
people don't want that automatic switch
they want to have more control and
so that's why they have it off by
default but
the docs are really good and clear
the search is pretty good sometimes
the descriptions of what is happening
aren't
tremendous but if you know a little bit
about css you can get because there is a
very much a one-to-one relationship
between these class names and what they
would be in css they're not trying to
hide them in
some magic component name
anyone else
now that we've broken the field no
well
are any of you jet lagged
wow are you all local
no neither okay
i'm gonna stop answering questions to
the blank stairs thanks for for coming
i'll put on my
my uh um
slide with all the links uh this demo
will be up on wilderness.com hopefully
by the end of today so you can grab it
if you're interested
dalwincss.com is the website i have a
youtube channel and a film i made about
developers so feel free to visit any and
all of those
thank you very much
you